artificial intelligence has seen a
substantial increase in popularity this
decade thanks to the mass adoption of
data science and machine learning in
every aspect of the it industry one such
promising venture is a new system that
promises to create realistic art imagery
from text descriptions hey everyone
today we are going to cover an
interesting ai model by the name of dali
2. before we move forward though ensure
you subscribe to our channel and the
bell icon is clicked so that you never
miss an update from simply learn if you
scroll through twitter and look for the
hashtag dolly2 you'll be greeted with a
plethora of images and artwork shared by
many people based on different topics
starting from victorian era styled
pictures of aliens to portrait style
images dali 2 has taken the ai crowd by
storm thanks to its photorealistic
creations this model is being developed
by a small group of data scientists
using models from open ai
a startup which is backed by microsoft
however public access has not been
provided on a widespread basis and there
is a waiting list for people wanting to
try out this ai system the company also
has investors confidence including ride
hoffman's charitable foundation and
costler ventures dolly too can make
realistic edits to existing images from
a natural language caption and add or
remove elements while considering
shadows reflections and textures the
full-fledged access for dali 2 is
currently restricted so the next best
choice is to use dali mini which draws
an open source code from a loosely
organized team of developers and is
often overloaded with demand anyone can
type in a prompt and hit the run button
though you're likely to get an error
message about traffic to the tool and
have to try again dali mini will spit
out its results in the form of a 3 into
3 grid which contains 9 images a note
about the tool on its website says it
was trained on unfiltered data from the
internet
the model has been trained by looking at
millions of images across the internet
tied to the captions
the program then builds up a database of
what an image looks like with its worded
prompt
while there are no doubts about how
impressive this technology is it isn't
without its limitations despite the
company's intentions this kind of
technology is tricky to deploy
responsibly with this in mind openai
says it is currently studying the
system's limitations and capabilities
with the select group of users the
company has already removed explicit
content from the training data to avoid
generating violent hateful or adult
images they also say that dali 2 cannot
generate photorealistic ai versions of
real individual fixes one other issue
you face is the confusion of certain
words of phrases
for example when you input a black hole
inside of a box dolly 2 returns a hole
that was black inside of a box instead
of a celestial body that the input query
may imply this can often happen when a
word has multiple meanings phrases can
be misunderstood or colloquialisms are
used this is to be expected from an
artificial intelligence speaking the
literal meaning of your words
another area where dali can become
confused is with variable blending
if you ask the model to draw a red cube
on top of a blue cube sometimes it gets
confused and does the opposite
dali mini has big competition
openai is slowly opening up its software
to the world allowing more people to use
dali too
google has now launched its competitor
imagine a model with similar accuracy to
openai's original invention
the growth of the ali2 has been
relatively slow thanks to the gradual
rollout to the public it will help
openair monitor its growth appropriately
develop its safety filters and prepare
its product for the future where
millions will eventually be generating
random images from text
if you found this video on the dali 2 ai
engine informative hit the like button
below and for any questions regarding
the topic drop your queries in the
comments we will help you as soon as
possible
thank you for watching and stay tuned
for new videos on simplylearn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here